7 червня виповнюється чотири роки,
як Петро Порошенко вступив на посаду президента.
Тоді він багато чого наобіцяв українцям.
До наступних президентських виборів залишається лише рік,
відповідно й часу на виконання його обіцянок обмаль.
Що досі залишається невиконаним?
Я чітко публічно задекларував, що
одразу ж після перемоги на президентських виборах
я вимушений,
я пообіцяв продати.
Продати усе, крім 5-го каналу -
такою була обіцянка Порошенка.
Однак нині це питання фактично "зависло".
Свою частку акцій "Рошен" Порошенко, за його ж словами,
передав у "сліпий" траст ще 2016-го року.
Проте покупця для кондитерської корпорації
начебто так і не знайшлося.
Тим часом у власності президента залишаються ще чимало активів,
зокрема Міжнародний інвестиційний банк та завод "Кузня на Рибальському".
Крім продажу бізнесу, господар Банкової обіцяв - цитата -
перекрити офшори, однак при цьому сам
неодноразово фігурував в офшорних скандалах.
Я вас запевняю, що на сьогоднішній день існують всі механізми,
ми все зробимо для того,
щоби курс із цих ганебних 13-ти був знижений.
Таку обіцянку майбутній президент дав у розпал
своєї передвиборної кампанії - у квітні 2014-го.
На той момент Росія вже анексувала Крим і розхитувала ситуацію на Донбасі,
а економічна ситуація в країні була на межі колапсу.
Під час президентства Порошенка національна валюта
продовжила падіння і в пікові моменти
сягала майже 30 гривень за долар.
Антитерористична операція не може і не буде тривати два-три місяці.
Вона має і буде тривати години.
Одразу після обрання Порошенко обіцяв
закінчити війну на Донбасі за кілька годин.
Так звана Антитерористична операція офіційно завершилася
лише через чотири роки. Щоправда,
йдеться не про кінець війни, а фактично про зміну назви:
замість АТО операція на Донбасі стала називатися Операцією об’єднаних сил.
Натомість бойові дії на Донбасі тривають і досі.
Але я і ми всі віримо, що український прапор
знову замайорить над багатонаціональним півостровом.
Про повернення анексованого Росією Криму
Порошенко говорить протягом усієї своєї каденції.
І навіть назвав це одним із завдань на 2018 рік.
Утім, попри всі заяви питання Криму
досі залишається невирішеним.
Своєю чергою, російський президент Володимир Путін наголошує:
повернення півострова Україні неможливе за жодних обставин.
Україна буде в Європейському Союзі!
Я вам це обіцяю.
Окрім безвізу та угоди про асоціацію,
Петро Порошенко обіцяв вступ до ЄС
вже у найближчому майбутньому.
Це, за його словами,  питання років, а не десятиліть.
Утім, ані оглядачі, ані європейські чиновники такий оптимізм не поділяють.
Примітно, що під час ратифікації Угоди про асоціацію Україна-ЄС
під тиском уряду Нідерландів було погоджено спеціальний додаток до документу.
У ньому було прописано, що асоціація не дає Києву
перспективу членства в ЄС і не дає українцям
права проживати й працювати на території Євросоюзу.